[Music]
in smurf village
there are Smurfs who play their part oh
and then Smurfette there are these guys
happy
brainy clumsy oh that's not even
convincing follow me I found a map to a
lost village but we'll have to go
through the Forbidden Forest Wow isn't
the Forbidden Forest unsafe and full of
dangerous the time is that every bin
next year we've got to stop them before
they find the truth I'll be like ah ah
don't be all like oh I'll be like well
Dee how you doing ah okay I guess
whatever you do don't eat all your
rations I don't wanna rush you think you
know the Smurfs I agree my rations are
coming yeah but you don't know the whole
story what's going on over there is this
the lost village look there they are
what do we want what if the
any skin giant claws we should be
prepared for whatever we find I'm really
freaking out you guys screw the lost
village
Oh huh really man I'm okay
you spread anis worrywart sometimes I
just feel blue krang's
shade throwers nosy so what's going on
over there and there's one thing they
have in common 100
Oh